j'ouvre notre second débat il porte sur
la diplomatie du séisme ses conséquences
politiques trois jours après le
tremblement de terre qui a frappé le
Maroc faisant plus de 2600 morts autant
de blessés principalement dans la région
montagneuse de la classe avant de
débattre du choix du royaume chérifien
de refuser pour l'instant les françaises
mais aussi des conséquences beaucoup
plus globales politiques dans le pays on
fait le point sur les secours avec sa
mère de chien trois jours déjà que
secouriste et habitants fouillent sans
relâche les décombres des habitations
des bâtiments détruits vendredi soir par
le plus violent séisme qui est jamais
connu le Maroc le dernier bilan fait
état de près de 2700 morts et presque
autant de blessés plus les heures
passent plus l'espoir de retrouver des
survivants s'amenuisent
les corps sa femme sont sous les
décombres il n'y avait personne pour
récupérer les corps nous vous demandons
de faire entendre notre voix auprès des
autorités nous voulons ouvrir la route
la destruction de routes et de ponts
compliquent l'arrivée des secours dans
les localités les plus reculées dans la
province d'alaouz épicentre du séisme
des villages entiers ont été détruits
jusqu'à Marrakech des dizaines de
familles se retrouvent sans abri soin
nourriture logement d'urgence les
besoins sont immenses le Royaume-Uni a
proposé son aide cette nuit un avion
militaire britannique est arrivé chargé
de matériel de sauvetage et d'équipe de
recherche
au cours des 10 prochains jours nous
allons un collaboration avec des
partenaires d'autres pays rechercher des
survivants et des personnes touchées par
l'effondrement des structures dans les
zones sinistrées en utilisant certains
de nos équipements de sauvetage
spécialisés et nos chiens de recherche
le Maroc a accepté l'aide de quatre pays
Royaume-Uni Espagne plus tard et émirats
arabzuni en revanche le royaume n'a pas
donné suite à l'offre d'assistance faite
par la France dans un contexte de
relations tendue entre les deux pays le
Maroc est souverain il est seul en
mesure de quels sont ses besoins et le
rythme auquel et souhaite que des
réponses soient apportées à son besoin
nous sommes à la disposition des
autorités marocaines et nous leur
faisons toute confiance pour organiser
les secours la France reste prête à
déployer une aide si le Maroc le demande
elle a également annoncé une enveloppe
de 5 millions d'euros aux ONG présentent
sur place
les conséquences du séisme notamment
politique diplomatique on en débat tout
de suite avec Pascal Bernard bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes sismologue à
l'Institut de géo physique du globe de
Paris j'accueille David insuline bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes sénateur de Paris
Président délégués du groupe socialiste
et membre du groupe d'amitié France
Maroc
bonsoir bienvenue professeur de droit à
l'UPEC Paris 12 consultant international
au cabinet Lysias partner c'est auteur
de ce livre relation internationales
droits théorique et pratique qui vient
de paraître aux éditions Pedone on était
également duplex avec Boris vellachieff
qui est taxi architecte ingénieur expert
en risque majeur bonsoir à vous et
bienvenue et Mathieu croissanto éditoris
politique est resté à mes côtés on va
démarrer sur le séisme lui-même Pascal
Bernard
quels sont les caractéristiques de ce
qu'on sait de la de la zone touchée la
zone touchée c'est l'Atlas marocain le
sud de l'Atlas marocain une zone qui se
déforme présentement d'un point de vue
tectonique donc ce séisme en quelque
sorte a une forte magnitude par rapport
à ce qu'on pouvait attendre cela dit les
géologues avaient déjà cartographié des
grandes failles actifs modérément actifs
mais quand elle casse elle en gros et là
c'est une grande faille peut-être 30-40
km de long qui a cassé en quelques
secondes et qui envoyer des eaux un peu
partout jusqu'à ces ressentis jusqu'à
des centaines de kilomètres de là ça
veut dire que c'est une zone sismique
mais avec assez rarement si je vous
comprends bien des des tremblements de
terre de d'une telle puissance c'est ça
le Maroc a une spécificité modérée plus
forte que la France mais moins forte que
l'Italie pour donner une échelle en
quelque sorte et donc des cellules
autour de 7 ne sont pas improbables ils
surviennent une fois peut-être on n'a
pas l'histoire mais on imagine une fois
tous les tous les 1000 ans c'est
l'échelle de temps de ce type de séisme
parce que historiquement on ne connaît
pas de tels de telle magnitude au Maroc
David Assouline vos premières pensées
elles vont j'imagine aux familles elles
vont aux victimes c'est ça que vous
voulez peut-être nous dire
prioritairement ce soir
oui bien sûr bon mon histoire
personnelle je suis né au Maroc je l'ai
quitté quand j'avais 8 ans pour arriver
en France et
le Maroc coule dans mes veines
j'aime manger marocain j'ai j'aime rire
marocain j'ai beaucoup d'amis
et j'ai tout de suite pensé que il y a
une injustice
il n'y a pas que de la fatalité en fait
parce que bien sûr ce séisme il tombe là
et c'est pas les hommes qui l'ont décidé
mais ce sont les pauvres qui trinquent
ce sont les pauvres qui meurent parce
que leurs habitations
sont très instables très précaires
pourtant il y a des normes antisismiques
qui sont censés s'imposer depuis une
vingtaine d'années au Maroc oui mais
aller dans les villages bien sûr aucun
et
alors on est souvent émerveillé par le
fait que c'est très typique très très
conforme à la façon dont on faisait il y
a longtemps mais ce sont des maisons qui
fabriquent de leurs mains et qu'il
reconstruiront probablement de leurs
mains aussi demain et bon voilà donc
c'est c'est je pense d'abord à ça à
cette et à cette fatalité mais aussi à
cette injustice parce que je vois bien
que même à Marrakech que l'on connaît
souvent quand on est français parce que
on y va et dans la médina le maila
notamment l'ancien quartier juif qui est
plus vieux
vous voyez les constructions bon malgré
une rénovation avec l'aide de la France
il y a pas si longtemps pour des raisons
de patrimoine de préservation du
patrimoine historique c'est effondré
mais on imagine dans les campagnes ça a
été absolument terrible on y reviendra
évidemment en détail est-ce qu'on peut
dire que cette catastrophe c'est aussi
un forme de test pour le Maroc pour son
organisation politique administrative
c'est aussi à ça que l'on assiste depuis
presque trois jours depuis 72 heures oui
c'est clair ce genre de crise
humanitaire c'est aussi une manière ou
plutôt l'opportunité l'occasion pour un
de tester les capacités
organisationnelles les infrastructures
d'un état et là pour le coup ça explique
pas mal de choses
du dans ce cas particulier dans la
mesure le Maroc comme on le sait
maintenant à sélectionner à trier on y
reviendra en détail voilà les pays qui
pouvaient intervenir sur son territoire
pour prêter assistance c'est aussi il
faut le comprendre aussi comme une
manière pour le Maroc de faire la
démonstration de ses capacités de son
autosuffisance en la matière on verra
bien si il passe ce test et puis et puis
on y viendra une dimension plus
diplomatique aussi qui va au-delà de
cette la question de l'image du Maroc a
aussi la question des rapports du Maroc
avec son voisinage avec les autres
acteurs régionaux et internationaux dans
la mesure où dans ce genre de crise il y
a ce qu'on appelle la diplomatie
humanitaire
qui se déploie et qui est une manière
pour les états de développer leur soft
power d'essayer de dégager une image
positive c'est ce qui explique là pour
le coup non pas forcément l'empressement
mais la volonté française d'être présent
d'intervenir de faire la démonstration
précisément d'être un allié proche du
Maroc et en même temps d'avoir à
déployer un savoir-faire aussi en la
matière
Boris Velia chef l'urgence en ce moment
évidemment c'est de retrouver des
survivants on avait vu en Turquie je
crois qu'on avait retrouvé une femme
survivante six jours et demi après le
tremblement de terre donc voilà on est
encore dans ce délai mais c'est aussi de
quoi d'inspecter toutes les
constructions qui qui tiennent encore
debout c'est ça fait partie de l'urgence
oui bien sûr chaque séisme c'est
spécificités liées aux séismes lui-même
puis après il y a le il y a les enjeux
qui sont détruits qui sont touchés ici
on a une on a des enjeux particuliers
avec elle on a vu camararachesse il y a
des quartiers anciens qui ont été
touchés mais les quartiers nouveau
justement qui sont soumis au règlement
par racisme et qui sont assez récents
puisqu'il date de 2002 ou au Maroc eux
ont été ont été préservés par contre
dans tous les villages de de l'Atlas en
fait des reliefs qui ont été touchés là
on a affaire comme ça a été dit à des
construction qui date d'avancent ces
règlements ou alors qui sont qui sont
soumis aucune règle qui ne dépendent pas
de ses règlements et qui sont en plus
dans des modes constructifs qui sont
différentes ceux de la Turquie par
exemple en Turquie on avait affaire à
des bâtiments qui étaient en
principalement en béton armé même s'il y
avait des mises en oeuvre souvent
déplorable ce qui a ce qui a fait que
ces bâtiments sont effondrés disons que
quand ça tombe vous avez des des grands
pas de murs des grandes dalles qui
peuvent créer éventuellement des espaces
de sous pour pouvoir préserver pour
qu'on puisse des poches pour qu'on
puisse y retrouver des survivants alors
qu'au Maroc on a affaire le plus souvent
à des constructions qui sont soit en
terre en ferragé la paille soit ce qu'on
appelle en masseurie nonchaînée avec des
petits éléments comme des pierres ou des
briques qui sont mises des unes sur les
autres mais tout ça ça s'effondre comme
des châteaux de cartes et ça fait des
petits éléments des petits gravats qui
fait que ça laisse beaucoup moins
d'espace pour pouvoir abriter
d'éventuelles survivants donc c'est plus
délicat par contre c'est vrai que ça les
on le voit d'ailleurs puisqu'il y a eu
un grand élan de solidarité entre
marocain ça c'est particulier à la
culture marocaine et on voit que les
gens arrivent à retirer les gravats
presque à la main ce qui a permis aux
gens d'intervenir assez rapidement
Pascal Bernard il y a encore des risques
de séisme oui bien sûr
combien de jours après c'est
alors il y a les répliques ordinaires je
dirais c'est celle qui ont des
magnitudes inférieures donc mais ça sera
peut-être une magnitude 6
statistiquement c'est un petit peu ça un
point de magnitude pour la plus grosse
réplique mais tu utilises ça peut faire
des dommages à 15 km à la ronde et ça ça
sera dans le voisinage de ce qui s'est
passé là donc dans la zone et puis
centrale il est pas encore intervenu
cette réplique n'est pas encore
et ça on s'y attend quelques unités
quelques dizaines et puis et puis il y a
le plus long terme c'est-à-dire à
l'échelle là c'est à l'échelle de
quelques semaines quelques mois et ce
qu'on attend peut-être et c'est en
observe assez souvent c'est des séismes
qu'on appelle ça en cascade c'est-à-dire
que la grande faille auquel perturbe un
petit peu elle fait des petits séismes
autour pendant les semaines des mois qui
viennent après et bien le système se
réajuste à plus grande échelle la plus
grande échelle de temps et d'espace et
peut-être les failles voisines à 10 20
50 km aussi puissante aussi capable
finalement vont se mettre à craquer et à
produire éventuellement un grand séisme
et donc c'est séisme en cascade ont des
échelles de temps d'interaction ça peut
être la née la dizaine d'années le
siècle et comme le cycle des céphaïs est
très lent puisque c'est une zone qui en
gros qui casse sous l'avidité tous les
tous les peut-être tous les minantes ou
éliminant c'est pas très bien de cette
zone là et bien on peut avoir des
séismes rapprochés à l'échelle de la
dizaine d'années ou les centaines
d'années ce qui probablement justifie le
démarrage de grosses études pour voir
dans quel état sont les failles voisines
est-ce qu'elle donne des signes de
d'affaiblissement suite à ce grand
séisme mais ça c'est très important on
peut pas prévoir un séisme je repose des
questions de base dans ce débat mais où
qu'est-ce qu'on peut prévoir parce que
c'est toujours une question qu'on se
pose tout dépend le prévision c'est très
large on fait des prévisions on fait des
prévisions réussies à long terme c'est à
dire qu'on dit voilà cette zone là
sismique on a un séisme étude 6 dans
cette région là tous les 100 ans ça on y
arriver relativement bien dans beaucoup
de pays au monde beaucoup de pays
sismiques
15 jours
on n'y arrive pas parce que les
phénomènes précurseurs qui annoncent la
rupture de la faille sont très rares on
peut dire qu'on les voit nettement une
fois sur 10 voilà mais une fois sur 10
parfois on voit quelque chose qui
ressemble à ça et finalement il se passe
rien voilà on en est là on est capable
ils ont délire il y a une menace à la
semaine ou au moins ou à l'année parce
que il y a tout à coup une activation de
tout petit séisme un endroit ça aurait
pu se produire là ça ne s'est pas
produit à ma connaissance pardon j'ai
posé une question de lui aussi mais ce
que ce que je comprends c'est que
c'était pas une zone sismique vraiment
c'est une zone sismique c'est une zone
de faille les septième montagneuse est
une des ce sont des montagnes anciennes
mais toujours active jeune en quelque
sorte elles sont rajeunies par le
mouvement des failles et ces failles
font que les montagnes se soulève
toujours et le soulèvement en fait se
fait pas lentement il se fait par un
coup à chaque séisme mais
sur des périodes de temps qui sont très
très longues est-ce que les failles
étaient étudiées parce qu'il y avait
il y a même des équipes françaises qui
ont travaillé il y a une vingtaine
d'années dessus il y a une très bonne
cartographie de ces failles par contre
on ne connaît pas leur activité une
Castel tous les Milan tous les 10.000
ans tous les 20000 ans on ne sait pas et
ça c'est très important pour dire à
manipule 7 comme celui-ci se
reproduit-il plus au nord plus au sud à
quelle fréquence et ça ça demande des
études d'ailleurs mes collègues de de
Montpellier et en géodésie propose une
dision de travailler sur cette chose-là
ils ont déjà des réseaux avec le Maroc
sur place et pour l'instant tout est
bloqué parce que la collaboration
scientifique avec la France n'est pas
encore ouverte réouverture
profitez-en vous avez un sismologue à
côté de vous
donc ça veut dire que cette faille n'a
rien à voir avec celle qui a craqué déjà
avec Agadir en 1960 ou avec parce que je
suis historien je mettais un peu penché
sur l'histoire de la région où je suis
né j'ai vu qu'au 17e siècle
avait été rasé quasiment avec des
milliers de morts
c'est pas les mêmes travail c'est c'est
pas la même faille mais c'est le même
système de faille il faut voir que la
une zone montagneuse c'est pas une
grande faille comme ça en Californie
c'est des petits segments qui sont
raboutés les uns à l'autre qui
fonctionne comme ils peuvent globalement
c'est comme s'il y avait une seule
faille mais elle casse par petit morceau
segmenté et donc c'est le même système
donc c'est pas Milo parce que je parlais
de ces bilan dans cette zone là dans
l'échelle de 50 100 km
et alors ça pose quand même la question
de la capacité d'un État en y revient au
stress etc enfin au tout une sorte de
test politique la capacité d'un état
face à une catastrophe comme celle-là
donc la difficulté de la prévision les
questions de formation les questions de
normes antisysmique je me tourne vers
Boris via chef là-dessus parce que je
crois que vous avez séjourné au Japon
alors évidemment les deux états sont
absolument pas comparables en termes de
richesse de développement etc mais dans
la culture du séisme qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire du Japon
bien sûr c'est l'un des rares pays où on
peut observer ce qu'on appelle
réellement une sorte de culture du
risque que c'est dans leur culture c'est
un sac il faut savoir que toutes les
grandes périodes historiques japonaises
si on regarde au milieu entre deux
périodes il y a souvent une grosse
catastrophe souvent assainissement
d'ailleurs ou une éruption volcanique
qui fait que ça démarre l'économie ça
relance même si c'est un énorme désastre
il y a une reconstruction qui se fait
après que le pays repart dans une
nouvelle période donc les japonais
depuis toujours sont très liés aux
événements à ces aléas naturellement en
fait et donc ils ont ils apprennent ça
très jeune c'est qu'il y a une éducation
faut savoir je raconte toujours une
histoire je vais essayer de faire court
parce que on a pas beaucoup de temps
mais quand je suis arrivé au Japon
moi-même je me souviens je me suis
retrouvé tout seul dans une pièce où il
y avait une femme âgée qui avait des
difficultés à discuter à se déplacer
pardon un petit enfant de 6-7 ans et
puis j'étais avec eux regardez la télé
et puis c'est déclenché un séisme un
séisme de d'une intensité un petit peu
moins que celle de heureusement que
celle de Marrakech enfin c'est quand
même important la le lustre s'est mis à
se balancer etc et le petit enfant de 6
ans c'est relevé très rapidement il est
allé couper le gaz couper l'électricité
il a ouvert les portes les fenêtres il a
mis quelque chose sur la tête de sa
grand-mère qui me passe déplacer il m'a
invité à aller sur la table et tout ça
dans un temps record et un câble Olympia
j'étais vraiment surpris le ciné s'est
réaction on voit que très jeune ils sont
éduqués à savoir réagir c'est très
important parce que ça permet de réduire
considérablement le nom de victimes en
cas de justement d'aller à majeur je
cherche pas à pointer des
responsabilités un Belling mais il y a
pas cette culture du du séisme au Maroc
c'est pas non plus le même niveau de de
risque sismique sans doute mais est-ce
qu'il y a des voix qui s'élèvent en ce
moment au Maroc qui posent ces questions
là sur est-ce qu’on a mis suffisamment
de Normandie sismiques est-ce qu'on a
suffisamment formé les les populations
vous voyez ce que je veux dire à se
préparer face à face à ce risque donc là
incontestablement on est encore
dans l'urgence
on est encore dans les dans la dernière
les dernières heures on peut encore
sauver des vies la spécisme mais c'est
ce que je sais 72 heures donc là jusqu'à
demain matin on peut encore sauver des
vidéos télé c'est ce qui est un agenda
de tous les Marocains donc on est dans
l'urgence on est dans le deuil aussi
donc on n'est pas encore dans le
questionnement et dans la posture
critique ça viendrait certainement ça
viendra oui ça viendra mais je pense
dans une version marocaine c'est à dire
ceux qui seront visés seront des
responsables administratifs des
entrepreneurs qui auraient mal fait leur
travail à cause de la corruption mais
pas la figure du Roi Mohammed VI
traditionnellement échappe pour grande
partie à toute forme de critique d'abord
parce que il y a quand même un risque
politique et pénal qui est avec
certaines critiques et puis
culturellement aussi c'est assez c'est
assez intégré le fait qu'on ne critique
pas le roi comme étant le responsable
finalement des malheurs liés finalement
la nature ou des faits politiques ou
autres donc voilà il y aura ce débat là
cette forme de critique il y a un début
de c'est pas une démocratie au sens plus
réaliste et libéral du terme mais il y a
la capacité au Maroc de développer une
opinion publique avec toujours ce ola ou
cette exception se bémol à l'égard de la
figure monarchique qui frappa l'objet
d'une critique particulière je pense
alors on parle de diplomatie du séisme
dans ce débat c'est une explication
qu'on avait déjà employé au moment du
tremblement de terre en Turquie on va
voir qu'il en est le même depuis trois
jours au Maroc avec Alexandre Poussard
qui va me retrouver sur sur ce plateau
rebonsoir Alexandre avec une aide
internationale on peut dire au
compte-goutte effectivement on l'a dit
seulement quatre pays sont autorisés par
l'État marocain à apporter une aide sur
le terrain il s'agit du Qatar du
Royaume-Uni de l'Espagne et des Émirats
arabes unis alors pourquoi soit ce choix
et bien les autorités marocaines se sont
justifiées dans un communiqué elles
expliquent qu'elles ont procédé à une
évaluation précise des besoins sur le
terrain en tenant compte du fait que la
non coordination dans de telles
situations pourraient être je cite
contre-productive alors donc c'est payé
autorisés ont commencé à se déployer un
avion du
Qatar du chargé de colis d'urgence à
décoller ce week-end d'une base aérienne
de DOA côté britannique des avions
militaires chargés de matériel de
sauvetage ont atterri à Marrakech avec
une équipe de spécialistes pour
retrouver des survivants l'Espagne de
son côté va mobiliser plus de 80
secouristes et une unité espagnole
spéciale d'urgence et déjà en train de
travailler de commencer les recherches à
Talat en Yacoub c'est une commune proche
de l'épicentre du séisme et d'ailleurs
le ministère de la défense espagnole
précise la mission qui a été confiée par
l'État marocain au secouriste espagnol
je le cite outre le travail de
localisation des victimes du tremblement
de terre et bien à cette unité
accueillera et coordonnera le reste des
équipes internationales dans la zone
d'urgence et d'autres pays sont prêts à
offrir leur aide au Maroc oui des
dizaines et des dizaines de pays ont
proposé leur assistance alors outre la
France qui a proposé son aide et qui va
développer à 5 millions d'euros pour les
ONG et bien les États-Unis ont assuré
qu'elles étaient prêtes à fournir une
assistante à une assistance sur place en
homme et en matériel le président Joe
Biden l'a confirmé Israël également avec
qui le Roi Mohammed VI a rétabli une
relation à diplomatique à proposer son
aide on va écouter le Premier ministre
Israël israélien
toute l'assistance possible au Maroc y
compris s'il le souhaite une équipe de
recherche et de sauvetage pour les
assister
d'Israël est aux côtés du Maroc en ces
temps difficiles
qui proposent leur aide au Maroc on peut
citer la Belgique qui comprend une forte
communauté marocaine la Turquie qui a
proposé vous voyez près de 300
secouristes et 1000 tentes d'urgence sur
place et on peut également citer
l'Algérie qui a rouvert les couloirs
aériens avec le Maroc et qui propose une
aide alors pour l'instant elle n'est pas
acceptée par le Maroc et ça paraît
compliqué quand on connaît les relations
très tendues entre les deux pays alors
est-ce que c'est ces autorisations au
compte-goutte peuvent bloquer
l'intervention d'OMG et sur place et
bien pas forcément par exemple il y a
certaines ONG françaises indépendantes
qui ont déjà commencé leur intervention
c'est le cas par exemple du Secours
populaire qui a des gens envoyés quatre
secouristes à Agadir et 150000 euros de
dons à des associations locales regardez
ce que dit le responsable du Secours
populaire je le cite nous n'avons pas
besoin du feu vert des autorités pour
intervenir un homme répondant pas un
appel de l'État marocain car nous
travaillons directement avec des
associations locales grâce aux liens
anciens tissés entre nos fédérations
départementales et en revanche et bien
certaines PNG dépendent du feu vert de
Rabat et des relations entre les États
c'est le cas de secouriste sans
frontières je vais citer là encore sa
responsable nous ne sommes pas une ONG
indépendante et nous ne partons pas si
le pays ne fait pas une demande d'aide
internationale donc la balle est quand
même dans le camp de Rabat pour
accélérer le déploiement de l'aide
humanitaire merci beaucoup Alexandre
pour ça c'était très très détaillé très
complet merci je me retourne vers vous
mais c'est quoi l'objectif du Maroc
pourquoi ces quatre pays comment on peut
le l'analyser l'expliquer c'est vrai que
c'est assez significatif c'est quatre
pays vis-à-vis desquels le Maroc s'est
rapproché de manière très significative
ces dernières années autour d'un axe
autour de deux axes ou deux dossiers le
dossier du Sahara Occidental d'une part
et le dossier du rapprochement qui sera
elle d'autre part ce qu'on appelle les
accords d'Abraham et là si vous prenez
en considération ces deux prismes ces
deux références vous comprenez grosso
modo la liste des quatre pays c'est
vraiment quatre pays qui se sont plus ou
moins alignés sur ces deux axes très
forts de la diplomatie rénovée du Maroc
Boris Velia chef je recherchais votre
nom pardon est-ce que le fait de
refuser ou de retour retarder on va dire
ça comme ça l'aide internationale pour
mieux l'organiser parce que c'est
l'argument qui est qui est donné par le
régime marocain est-ce qu'on peut
entendre cet argument est-ce que c'est
inhabituel ou pas ça
non c'est pas une habituel ça a été le
cas aussi au Japon après le tsunami de
2011 il y a énormément de tête qui a été
proposée et le Japon a pris vraiment
cette aide avec parcimonie parce que il
faut savoir que si tout le monde arrive
en même temps avec plein de matériel
plein de gens dans toutes les directions
il est certain que ça peut gêner ça a
été le cas dans plusieurs des astres
d'ailleurs je me souviens par exemple
que durant les inondations de au
Pakistan il y avait des équipes qui
étaient il y a plein de gens qui sont
venus il y a des équipes qui s'étaient
mises à adressées des tentes pour
pouvoir vacciner des populations alors
personne n'avait demandé ça gênait la
circulation en fait des secours donc ça
demande une organisation certaine et
c'est le Maroc est un État souverain
c'est à lui de dévaluer les besoins
qu'il a le plus rapidement possible on
souhaite et puis au pays comme la France
et autres qui ont pas encore été appelés
à se tenir prêt un éventuel appel mais
disons qu'après c'est au Maroc de
décider la France a évidemment
immédiatement proposé son aide Emmanuel
Macron l'a fait savoir c'était depuis le
sommet du G20
à New Delhi on écoute
envoyer SMS Majesté Roi Mohammed VI
évidemment un message directement nous
avons mobilisé l'ensemble des équipes
techniques de sécurité pour pouvoir
intervenir quand les autorités du Maroc
le jugeront utile et en tout cas nous
sommes mobilisés les échanges se font
entre ministres et techniciens et nous
avons ce matin
mobilisé la Banque Mondiale le FMI
l'Union européenne et l'Union africaine
pour ensemble avec la France justement
marqué aussi un engagement fort de
soutien au Maroc au peuple marocain pour
la reconstruction et l'aide financière
dans ce contexte
Mathieu il faut expliquer ce qui est en
train de se passer évidemment c'est un
signe de relation entre la France et le
Maroc qui sont pas bonnes le fait que le
Maroc n'est pas placé la France dans
cette première liste de pays c'est une
attitude qui a surpris tout le monde ici
parfois dans des élans il faut le dire
aussi un peu autocentré
un peu indécent comme si le principal
problème était de savoir si les français
étaient accepté plutôt que les scènes
auxquelles on assiste là-bas sur le
terrain mais c'est vrai qu'il y a une
forme de paradoxe entre les images de
désolation voir d'extrême dénuement
qu'on peut voir dans certains portages
et puis ce refus d'une main tendue par
la France mais pas que alors notre
orgueil national en a pris évidemment
pour son grade d'autant qu'on vient de
le rappeler l'Espagne et le Royaume-Uni
les Émirats le Qatar eux sont sur le
terrain tandis que nous nos sauveteurs
nos équipes qui savent aussi faire le
boulot reste sur le pont officiellement
c'est-à-dire si on écoute les voix
officielles les communautés et les
communiqués au ciel là aussi ça a été
rappelé il n'y a aucun problème pas de
querelle déplacé il a dit la ministre
des Affaires étrangères ce matin
Catherine Colonna tandis que le royaume
chérifien parle à la fois de son
ministère d'intérieur a expliqué au fond
la préoccupation et vous y avez fait les
gens étaient dans le logistique pour
identifier les besoins organiser ce
cours et éviter une forme de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler une insur accident par
le fait que trop de gens soient présents
la France je l'ai dit est d'ailleurs pas
la seule à rester sur le banc et puis on
l'a vu avec tous les drapeaux des jeux
des pays qui ont proposé leur aide mais
c'est une particularité nous sortons
quand même d'une période où les
relations diplomatiques entre les deux
pays ont été très abîmés alors on va
détailler ce qui ne fonctionne pas
d'abord c'est pas nouveau déjà sous le
quinquennat de François Hollande que les
Marocains avaient surnommé l'Algérien au
moment de son élection pour ces liens
supposés de grandes proximités avec le
pouvoir algérien plutôt qu'avec le
pouvoir marocain la relation c'était
vraiment tendue sous le quinquennat de
François Hollande et notamment autour de
questions de de sécurité mais avec
Emmanuel Macron ça ne s'est pas arrangé
à un point comme au mois de février
dernier dans une un discours sur la
relation entre la France et l'Afrique et
Macron a été interrogé par un
journaliste marocain il avait répondu
que les relations personnelles étaient
amicales avec avec Mohammed VI et trois
jours après dans Jeune Afrique le
gouvernement marocain par la voie d'une
source anonyme mais du gouvernement à
marocain avait dit que les relations
n'étaient ni amicales ni même bonne ni
entre les gouvernements ni entre les
deux palais alors les griefs ils sont
très nombreux de part et d'autre Paris
reproche au Maroc depuis longtemps son
manque de coopération sur la sécurité
mais aussi dans la gestion et l'accueil
des ressortissants marocains qui sont
expulsés de France et que le Maroc ne
veut pas forcément reprendre et puis
même s'il ne s'en est jamais pris au
royaume chérifien directement sur ce
dossier il y a quand même un petit
problème c'est que vous souvenez le
consortium international journaliste a
révélé qu'un logiciel option fabriqué en
Israël qui s'appelle le projet Pegasus
avait été utilisé ou en tout cas
commandé par certains pays dont le Maroc
et qui avait mis dans son dans son
viseur des portables officiels dont le
portable du président de la République
Emmanuel Macron donc ça c'est les griefs
côté français côté marocain maintenant
on a très peu apprécié pour le coup les
mesures de rétorsion qui avait été prise
par le gouvernement français dans cette
fameuse question des ressortissants
marocains qui n'est pas accepté vous
savez ce qui avait fait Paris on avait
sucré tous les visas on avait fait pour
le Maroc pour l'Algérie en effet pour
pour la Tunisie mais alors ça ça a été
rétabli en décembre dernier mais ça a
quand même empoisonné la relation
diplomatique et puis il y a ce dossier
que vous avez évoqué qui est le refus de
la France de reconnaître la souveraineté
du Maroc sur le Sahara Occidental alors
que l'Espagne l'a fait le Royaume-Uni
est vraisemblablement en passe de le
faire mais on voit que ça n'explique pas
non plus toute la géopolitique de l'aide
puisque il y a des pays qui l'ont
reconnu et qui ne sont pas donc cette
question du Sarah occidental ça fait
combien d'années qu'elle complique on va
dire les relations entre entre la France
et le Maroc
déjà c'est la priorité de l'activité
diplomatique marocaine c'est le dossier
prioritaire obsessionnel même du point
de vue marocain donc
la position de analyser les relations
par nos interrompre du Maroc avec
presque n'importe quel pays autre pays à
l'aune de cette question du Sahara
occidentale de fait de fait c'est
obsessionnel c'est presque existentiel
c'est-à-dire que pour le royaume
marocain il existe internationalement à
travers son territoire et il a une
représentation de ce territoire sauf que
cette représentation là est inclut le
territoire dit du Sahara Occidental ce
qui n'est pas encore reconnu à l'échelle
internationale à l'échelle de l'ONU ni à
l'échelle des grandes puissances
mondiales toutefois depuis ces dernières
années on a affaire à une offensive
diplomatique marocaine qui commence à
porter ses fruits qui se traduit par la
reconnaissance
de la souveraineté marocaine sur ce
territoire avec des dates ou des actes
clés puisque les États-Unis de Donald
Trump l'ont fait
Israël de netanyou la fée et donc qui a
un effet domino et manque à l'appel la
France et le Maroc garde à l'esprit et
pardon l'Espagne l'a fait qui a aussi un
passé colonial comme la France vis-à-vis
du Maroc donc voilà c'est cette absence
là qui fait qui fait qui fait mal d'une
certaine manière mais en même temps il
faut bien savoir qu'une relation
bilatérale elle peut pas se concevoir
qu'à l'échelle des deux États concernés
elle s'inscrit à la fois à l'échelle
régionale et internationale et à
l'échelle régionale qui dit relation
bilatérale entre la France et le Maroc
dit forcément
la relation ou la question entre la
France et l'Algérie évidemment puissance
régionale et l'autre élément aussi qui
fait que ce dossier prend une certaine
résonance aujourd'hui c'est côté
français c'est que on a aussi un côté
effet domino on a l'impression d'être
exclu de la zone
sert à rien
à cause des coups d'État qui sont
succédés au Burkina Faso ma ligne gère
etc et là on a l'impression d'être
rejeté au moins sur le plan diplomatique
par le Maroc l'impression cumulée
commence à nourrir plus qu'un malaise
peut-être une réalité se déclassement de
du poids de la France dans un espace où
il régnait du point de vue de son
influence est-ce que vous craignez ce
déclassement est-ce que vous reprenez
cette formule David la souligne
parce que
du point de vue des relations
économiques
elles ont jamais été aussi bonnes on va
dire
les relations commerciales les échanges
etc et donc les Français sont là donc
beaucoup d'entreprises françaises qui
travaillent au Maroc et très souvent on
dit que la politique c'est la mise au
mot en évidence et et en
œuvre de ce type de relation politique
quand il s'agit d'être bien pas là c'est
à dire que il y a quelque chose qu'il
faut essayer d'analyser c'est contre
tous ce qu'on nous avait très bien
exposé
le Maroc est un État souverain qui
essaye d'envoyer le message que il peut
faire sans la France
ça vous choque ça même si je suis
d'accord avec Mathieu c'est pas
l'élément le plus important depuis trois
jours mais je veux que ces relations
politiques se
réchauffe et
on adéquation avec la relation entre ces
peuples parce que
le grand écart c'est que j'ai été
bouleversé même par la solidarité qui
s'exprime en France tout de suite c'est
comme presque si ça se passait dans un
département français un peu éloigné
certes mais donc c'est vécu cette ce
séisme avec beaucoup plus d'émotions de
sentiments de solidarité d'envie de
faire que pour d'autres dans le monde
donc il y a cette solidarité ça faut
faut appeler à cette solidarité qu'elles
seront fortes et elle n'est pas freinée
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des ONG et ça va
passer aussi par les ONG il est donc il
faut pas dire on foncer l'attention ils
vont être bloqués en France tout ce
qu'ils vont donner tout ce qu'ils vont
faire
la Fondation de France il y a beaucoup
d'associations qui vont utiliser cet
arbre et puis après le deuxième jugement
c'est de se dire mais est-ce qu'on est
en train de refuser une aide qui serait
vitale parce que il y a pas des
capacités de la voir autrement quand on
voit des dizaines voire centaines de
pays qui veulent faire et qui ont des
capacités au moins cumulaient aussi
grandes que la France c'est pas au
détriment du secours des populations je
pense le fait de mais il y a
probablement un message qui est le
message
vous avez été ancienne puissance
coloniale on a des relations
remarquables mais vous ne pouvez pas
penser que c'est sans contrepartie et
sans échanges notamment par rapport à la
relation avec l'Algérie puisque la
France moi j'ai quand même été choisi
mais est-ce que vous est-ce que vous
vous dites que la France devrait
reconnaître la la le Sahara Occidental
marocain moi je pense que il faut que
sur cette question la France bouge de
toute façon et et revoit sa position
à l'aune de ce qui se passe dans cette
région et du développement et de le
Pinçon dont les populations doivent se
vivre des choses elle-même mais alors
mais je vous donnerai je vais vous
donner un petit exemple qui m'ont choqué
dans cette relation il y a dernièrement
ça a beaucoup ému dans la population
marocaine il y a deux jeunes qui ont été
tués par les autres par l'armée
algérienne parce que ils sont rentrés
dans les autres territoriales en faisant
du
scooter
deux jeunes de 20 ans qui était
franco-marocain
je ne comprends pas ils sont français
pourquoi la France n'a pas parlé avec
peu de force là-dessus imaginez deux
jeunes Français qui ont été tués
et c'est là qu'on voit aussi
ce qui ce qui est ressenti au Maroc
comme comme façon de ne pas traiter tout
le monde de la même façon Boris velhf je
reviens vers vous sur le la période
actuelle c'est à dire voilà
ces journées où il y a encore un espoir
de trouver des survivants est-ce que et
je reprends ce que ce que nous disait le
sénateurs est-ce que le fait de refuser
ou de retarder l'arrivée de sauveteur
peut avoir des conséquences ou est-ce
que effectivement parce que on entend
qu'il y a beaucoup de villages isolés
enfin voilà moi il y a des sauveteurs en
étant très basiques je vais dire puis il
y a de sauveteur plus il y a de chances
de sauver des de retrouver des
survivants
évidemment aux questions moyen mais
disons que le Maroc ce temps s'est assez
souverain et un pays qui possède qu'à
assez de moyens ils ont une armée
organisée ils ont du matériel ils vont
faire appel à de l'aide de toute façon
donc
se précipiter tous ensemble je sais pas
si ça résoudrait plus rapidement le
problème et on est obligé de respecter
en fait leur évaluation des besoins
qu'ils auront donc
c'est difficile de s'initier de
s'immiscer dans ce genre de de ce genre
de départ en fait est-ce que
Nabil le
tout à l'heure dans cette décision de de
on va dire accepter quatre pays et
seulement quatre pays pour l'instant
est-ce que c'est le roi qui prend une
telle décision dans le système politique
marocain du point de vue constitutionnel
tout ce qui relève du régalien le
monarque Mohammed VI demeure l'autorité
de référence c'est lui qui décide c'est
le pouvoir décisionnaire donc les
questions diplomatiques de cette nature
bien sûr bien sûr que c'est lui qui a
arbitré tranché et décidé d'accord je
vous propose un témoignage on va revenir
un peu à la situation d'urgence
justement dans ces villages les plus
isolés écoutez cet habitant
10 min tala il réclame de l'aide
les gens sont très déprimés ici le
village d'iminthala est complètement
démoli il n'y a plus personne pour les
aider leur falaise leur est tombée
dessus les gens sont encore sous les
décombres personne ne peut enlever les
pierres et les autorités n'ont pas
encore envoyé le matériel pour les
enlever
ce qu'elle ne l'ont pas fait depuis
trois jours
on sent l'odeur des cadavres partout
c'est dommage que les autorités n'aient
pas aidé ces gens
il faut peut-être expliquer la
difficulté d'acheminer les secours dans
certains de ces villages les plus les
plus reculés on comprend évidemment le
la réaction de cette de cette habitant
mais il y a des routes qui elle-même ont
été totalement détruites c'est ça oui
les images sont assez parlantes c'est un
relief qu'on connaît assez bien
caractéristiques montagneux etc mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'il c'est
aussi l'une des clés de compréhension de
la position marocaine une part de
rationalité dans leur communiquer
officielle qui consiste à dire on ne
peut pas accueillir toute l'assistance
internationale parce que ça serait
contre-productif vous imaginez les
camions qui il y a pas les voix si les
routes ne sont pas rétablies à quoi ça
sert elles ont été elles-mêmes affectées
donc les infrastructures même relatives
relativement développées ont été
atteintes et ne peuvent pas assurer
l'acheminement de l'aide internationale
donc encore une fois je trouve que le
discours actuel du royaume marocain a
une part de politique internationale il
y a un message qui a envoyé tel ou tel
partenaire la France comprise et il y a
une part aussi de rationalité qu'on peut
très bien comprendre pour un état qui à
la fois un État souverain naturellement
mais surtout surtout qu'il y a un état
qui revendique un leadership régional
c'est qu'il faut comprendre lorsqu'on
dit c'est un État souverain de fait bien
sûr que c'est un État souverain et
surtout il essaie de faire la
démonstration d'être un grand dans cette
région David la souligne
d'expliquer aussi c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
une part de messages et
quand on connaît le Maroc
on sait que il y a une certaine honneur
à montrer que
malgré la misère malgré c'est un état
qui est en capacité même on l'a vu du
point de vue médical la façon dont les
dons du sang sont récoltés
la mise en mouvement de de tout un tas
de services de santé qui n'existent pas
dans des pays disons moins développés
ils ont ces capacités et de dire que
quand il y a autant de propositions
d'aide sur les domaines où ils peuvent
avoir des difficultés des tables ils
sont en capacité aussi de dire que comme
tout le monde ne peut pas arriver en
même temps c'est un tel ou tel c'est là
qui a peut-être le message diplomatique
quand on n'a pas mis en haut de la liste
la France alors que l'on sait très bien
que c'est la France qui du point de vue
culturel du point de vue de ces
relations y compris de population
franco-marocaine ici de liens avec les
familles là-bas même quand on sait qu'à
4 millions de touristes français qui
vont au Maroc qui ont été bon on peut se
dire c'est naturel de dire d'abord la
France et bien la relation diplomatique
fait qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas naturel
mais je répète je ne pense pas que c'est
au détriment avec les éléments que j'ai
bien sûr je n'ai pas tout que c'est au
détriment de du sauvetage de population
puisque les États qui ont été retenus
peuvent le faire que il y a ces
problèmes d'infrastructures pour arriver
sur les lieux et tout ça ce sont des des
explications rationnelles c'est
peut-être ça qui brouille un peu notre
lecture des choses il y a une
dissociation à garder à l'esprit dès
lors qu'on parle de relation
internationales ou d'un fait
international vous avez d'un côté les
monstres froids que sont les états et
vous avez de l'autre ben les humains les
individus qui eux peuvent entretenir des
relations de par-delà les frontières il
y a effectivement une communauté
marocaine qui transnationale qui vit à
la fois en France et au Maroc et vous
avez des Français résident permanents au
Maroc bon naturellement qu'on imagine
très bien qu'ils ont qu'ils vivent d'une
manière très particulière ce qui se
passe puis de contre vous avez des États
qui ont un agenda particulier qui sont
qui vont au-delà de l'urgence qui qui
pensent leurs intérêts à long terme et
c'est intérêts à long terme ne sont pas
affectés par la situation aussi
dramatique que celle-ci ce sont des
monstres froids pour reprendre
l'expression de Nietzsche parlant des
états on va tiens je vous propose un
dernier élément parce que peut-être on
nous entend nous écoutant une vitesse
que ça est-ce que j'aide ou pas le les
habitants du Maroc un témoignage un tout
dernier témoignage
elle s'appelle Karine mol et responsable
des urgences à la Fondation de France a
été ce matin sur France Inter elle parle
de l'effet de Falaise vous allez
comprendre pourquoi on peut on doit
aider les Marocains souvent ce qu'on
observe après une catastrophe un grand
élan générosité les financeurs qui
arrivent et puis au bout de six mois
vous voyez c'était la Turquie il y a 6
mois
d'Ukraine les gens oublient les
financeurs s'en vont et les associations
se retrouvent tout d'un coup sans moyens
au moment même
où il faut passer au travail le plus
coûteux la reconstruction la
réhabilitation des écoles la relance
économique des populations c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'effet falaise et c'est
pour ça que l'argent que nous collectons
nous en consercrons consacrant une
partie à l'aide d'urgence immédiate bien
sûr mais nous gardons aussi en
perspective cette phase où les
associations vont avoir besoin plus que
jamais de notre aide pour penser
l'avenir voilà je voulais terminer ce
débat avec ce témoignage merci à tous
d'y avoir participé je vais rappeler le
titre de votre livre Bellini relation
internationales droits théorie et
pratiques qui vient de paraître aux
éditions Pedone voilà je vous dis à
demain 18h 22h sur Public Sénat merci à
toutes et à tous de votre fidélité notez
également l'invité politique Dorian
Mancini demain matin c'est Jean-François
Copé l'ancien ministre et maire actuel
mais elle est de mots belle soirée